back when i was still doing youtube
stuff um i would i went on this like
camping trip
with a few of my friends and we went to
this area that had
absolutely no reception whatsoever oh
whales
yeah we went all the way to wales no we
we were just in the [ __ ] middle of
nowhere in australia with
no reception and we would just went
camping and because there's no reception
i couldn't check anything right like i
couldn't like i couldn't even like mess
it up
this is like a light version yeah it's
basically just like a dieting yeah a
diet version of it but
i i kind of had like a similar
experience to that but only like for
that one day and i remember
the first couple of hours i [ __ ]
hated it because
i was getting those you know like drug
addicts like i need i need to know who
liked my tweet
but after a while like when it hit
around midday i i eventually was like
you know what this is actually
really nice like yeah the world is
beautiful that's why i love going to the
cinema like it's a
no one can like be like why don't you
answer your phone like yeah in every
other situation like oh you should have
answered this deal in the cinema for
some reason it was like understandable
have a nice day
you ignored my text for three hours
understandable you just like a void
right it's great like i love it you just
literally ignore the world for like
three hours and just have fun
yeah and that's why it frustrates me
when the void gets
pulled back to reality when someone in
the back is just [ __ ]
shouting yeah yeah just being like oh
yeah i forgot this is reality
because especially now i think i don't
know the internet's i feel like has
reprogrammed
my brain yeah i don't remember i don't
know if i just have adhd
because i didn't always felt like i was
this easily distracted
it's like subconsciously building
patterns in your head though like
because
you you've trained your brain to check
twitter
yeah and so you'll you you'll have that
moment and i'm sure you've all had it
where you're like you opened twitter you
closed twitter and you opened twitter
again
and you're like why did i open twitter
again yeah like i didn't want to open
like i literally just refreshed my feet
two seconds ago i didn't want to do this
i just didn't
you check twitter on your computer and
you realize there's nothing nothing you
checked
it and then you immediately check it on
your phone why am i doing this i wasted
ten seconds
it's the same concept as going to the
fridge seeing nothing there closing it
sitting back on the couch and then five
minutes later going to the fridge
it's like it's like food's gonna
magically appear in the freezer right
yeah so i i mean it was it was
it was an awesome experience for me i
like i don't you know if
if that's not something that's if not
that's it it's not an experience for
everyone
the question is though would you do it
again um i
would do it again possibly maybe not to
this extreme because i do i feel like
i'm in a lot better place in my life i'm
a lot more privileged now
no i mean like like not not just not
just that but like mentally
yeah i'm in a lot better place in my
life as well um so i don't feel
i would need to go to that extreme again
but would i want an experience where i
just
kind of just remove myself from the
world and just give myself
it's like a short detox yeah yeah yeah
that's that's it's like a detox from the
mind yeah this is how i feel it
and i i highly recommend people doing
that it sounds
really cheesy because people will always
think of that lyric some
some crazy californian gap yeah i
like going on a gap yeah i took a gap
year to thailand became a mom
that right i was just like shut up dude
you probably went to the club every
night like shut up yeah
so that's why i don't really talk i
don't really like to talk about it
because when whenever whenever you say
yeah i've been sound pretentious it
sounds pretentious people give you that
look to be like
why because it makes it sound like you
it was like a vacation for you whereas
it was probably someone's life right
yeah yeah that's why it sounds
or maybe or maybe it sounds like it
because maybe some people think you just
went through it just to brag about it
like later on yeah yeah exactly
the fact that you've you you don't
really talk about this
i never talk about this i remember i i
dragged you i dragged that conversation
out of you
we were like really drunk in singapore
like three
years ago i think i just drunkly
offhanded mentioned mention
i was like hold on you're a mom